[Music]
so the philosopher Joseph Campbell used
to say that when we are transfixed by
beauty we are beheld in a kind of
aesthetic arrest okay
so transfixed that we stopped breathing
we well up inside we experience what
Camus says as life lived to the point of
Tears right and why do we love these
experiences so much because they arrest
time they freeze time they forced us to
marvel they allow us to become
contemplative beings to enter those head
spaces outside of normal Euclidean space
and time and provide a kind of respite
of the human condition right we
temporarily step off that people-mover
that's carrying everyone else towards a
death and we become gods outside of time
reveling in a kind of ecstatic
illumination staring into the Sun and
being moved by it's magnificent opulence
you know but the universe singing in
rapture and us just like drowning in it
it's like the last scene in the movie
the fountain when he becomes like the
bubble that explodes in space you know
there's a kind of mythic death and
rebirth this is really resurrection
happening you know it's it's we smash
our sense of separateness in these
moments and
yeah it's kind of wonderful I just think
that's why we do it it's therapy eyes
therapy inspiration is therapy
[Music]